[Music]
hi guys welcome back to the newest
episode of our podcast my name is Dian
to my left we have Mr Leon hello and to
my right we have Mr lisan hello today
we're going to be talking about sports
and uh we're going to be taking a main
focus on football as that is is our
favorite sport isn't that right yes MH
so what do you guys think does football
have a big effect on lives of the
young yes it does a lot of children play
football every day and uh a lot of
people dream to be a professional
footballer and I think it affects
everyone's lives who watches the sport
and uh of course we have our own
professional athlete here yes I mean
football is the best sport out there
yeah uh so many people have passion
about
it and yeah what's you guys' favorite
football team I'm uh I'm wearing the
Jersey now Barcelona yeah Barcelona what
about you and we have a Bayern fan in
the middle here not very good relations
eh no uh so what do you think uh what
makes you like Barcelona so much did you
did you watch it when you were younger
did you just suddenly find the team more
how did you guys get into liking FC
Barcelona um I accidentally saw a
Classico I was at my grandma's house and
it was on the TV and I liked it and I
chose the red the red and blue team and
then so now I support Barcelona yeah
same I was watching
uh the El Classico against Real Madrid
and Messi just was too good so I had to
be uh for me I think uh I think the
first game I ever remember seeing was
the uh Champions League final between
Bayern and Dortmund a Classico of our
own uh and I remember yeah I remember uh
Bayern won 2-1 uh or 31 I don't remember
2-1 yeah exactly uh and uh leandi called
a penalty back then he played for
Dortmund and uh yeah ever since then
I've just been a a bayy my own life uh
also a little bit for me it's a little
bit political because uh uh I didn't
want to support any Spanish team as uh
as uh Spain does not recognize Kosovo
our country catalunia does Cataluna does
in that case yes that's true uh what's
your guys's favorite football player is
it Messi or is it someone else it's
Messi it's Messi what about other than
Messi who do you guys think is the oh I
love verati verati I know he's in Qatar
now bit washed he's still very good I
love him yeah ronaldino man he's too
good I think probably mine is uh is your
favorite
or who are you talking about your
favorite or yeah my my favorite player I
think it would be between kimich and
Neuer they're both Club Legends they've
both uh been the best in their position
at one point okay uh so yeah it's
between one of them two and Neer is a
legend nor is a big Legend man probably
one of the best goalkeepers of all time
maybe even the best goalkeeper time
messy bar
though stop comparing two different
positions it's uh what about retired
players uh retired
players yeah um I don't know who do you
go for retire yeah um maybe Chavi I like
Chavi Chavi good D
Alvis yeah bit controversial bit
controversial after after what happened
s
son it would probably be R9 R I don't
know I feel like if he didn't have the
injuries that he had I think it'd be you
know up there with a Messi debate
probably M better he was stop saying
that it was probably uh yeah I
mean it's uh it's insane the the numbers
he put in
yeah uh what about the Champions League
who do you think that uh which team do
you think yeah this year I have to
support my team out there in Barcelona
we've been cooking in the group stases
and I support them as well but I don't
think so this is a
realistic the strong contenders are
realistically Man City are probably
going to win again yeah yeah
Chelsea I doubt they're going to go for
the for the two piece I don't think
they're going to do it they don't want
to do it or they can't do it I don't I
don't think they have it in them I don't
think the players are motivated enough
to go for a back to back champ League
maybe Bayern I don't think Bayern are
going to win I think we have good
chances there's just a little bit of a
form problem right now I don't I don't
know if Tel has fully settled in for the
club yet uh because as we've seen in the
Bundesliga and the Champions League
we've been we've been conceding a lot of
goals even though we're scoring a lot
and Harry kanane is a massive upgrade uh
but I think we're just not that stable
defensively uh I think I think PSG if
they manage to regain their form I think
they have a decent team I think it's
it's better than last year because last
year they were too there was no
chemistry in the team there was no
connection nothing happening there uh
that's true but I think if they can
manage to find a form they have a better
manager now as well I think they can uh
they can really go far I think Aral win
think if PSG win PSG can win mbappe
needs to be in form right now he's not
in form and that is true is the most
they have so many new players so they
just need to you know keep their team
together
oh you know I agree I think I think they
made some great signings uh considering
they lost probably two of the best
players out there uh one Messi went to
enter Mi as well best I I don't rate
verati that much sure it's a loss uh
best midfielder in PSG history PSG
history yes but they don't really have
that much history to to go off what
about Newcastle what about them I don't
they are good no I don't H I don't know
they' they haven't been to the Champions
League in a very long time they have to
focus on both the Premier League and the
Champions League now I think it's too
much for them I think they they might
pull out of the groups over
Milan uh depends on on how the game
between Milan and Newcastle in Newcastle
goes because they have some sick fans
like the game against PSG I think the
fans played a massive role in the win uh
but I don't think they're going to go
much further than that to be honest what
do you guys think uh uh which team is
going to be an underdog someone a dark
horse champ league in the Champions
League
yes somebody who don't expect to go that
far that might go far you
know um I I don't know I think Newcastle
could if they keep their form they've
been playing well so far but think
Manchester United
l oh maybe
even as well do you think do you think
alas goes through over man united I
think if they win if they play Maguire
in the team I think they can really do
something Maguire plays for for galatas
talking about gasar here no I don't I
don't know I think they have a good team
who who else is in the group Copenhagen
I think Copenhagen and Copenhagen both
home and away it's another six points I
think they'll go through Byron will beat
them and you could still draw points I
think I think we might draw against
katas I just I I don't know I feel a
draw in their Turf yeah and the Turkish
fans they go they go big they go hard
they they have some great fans over
there which is hard you know a massive
influence to the game do you think do
you think uh home games and away games
they have a lot of influence do you
think big difference really yeah for
example uh even in the national teams
right if albo or Kosovo play away it's
not the same as playing in albo or kovo
cuz they don't have their home fans yeah
they have fans there but it's not going
to be the same sport or any other club
you can see the between some Barcelona
when they play at home you know in
Barcelona and when they play away big
difference both of you can speak about
the Albania you've been to the same yes
we recently were in uh in Albania we saw
we watched the Albania versus czechia
game uh and I got to say the atmosphere
it was absolutely amazing uh and it
ended it resulted in Albania playing a
really really good game and now in the
end our chances to go to the euro are
actually you know they're like
99% almost there we need one more win I
think to go through as second place just
a draw and we're in I I don't know about
a draw but I think just a win and uh I
think we win we play uh I think uh far
Islands yeah far islands is our last
game I think that's got to be a win and
it's our horn Turf as well we play mova
away mova away mova away is might be a
difficult game because they also have
chances of qualifying and it's like the
first time they're seriously making it
there so they also have a lot of spirit
and there's a lot of motivation to go
through which is the same as us so but
I'm I'm I'm going to be booking tickets
to Germany already yeah you know the
hotels and everything we got to get got
get about
us let's skip let's skip not not not a
very good uh discussion topic I think
the the win was way too it was our first
win this weekend you should have had
four at this point by now at least four
yeah we've been
rubed not really we just been B
we've just been bad uh no no we have to
support them we have been robed I mean I
think we have a wonderful team I think
we have a lot of talent we have a lot of
players who play internationally but uh
I don't know the chemistry is in there I
don't know if if it's the if it's the
coach I don't know we play horrible we
just play We cross continuously I think
we just depend on some some players we
do we depend on a lot of players and
also we have horrible fullbacks the
fullbacks the difference between Al
I was seeing all the times ALB were
playing you know coming inside on the
wing we would have crossed instantly see
I think I think with with Kosovo what
happens is they group up the players
they take them and there's like go out
and play there's no tactics a lot of
bias like samiron he hasn't had a club
for three years now he hasn't played in
the club for three years and he's still
getting called up valisha got dropped by
his Club he didn't just end his contract
he got for and he started the next I'm
better than
I'm he was uh I don't know for
me uh there needs to be a big change in
the Federation for us to to actually go
through with something cuz we do have
good football players yeah and we have
you know good fans we have fans who are
passionate which as you said makes a
great influence to the game we need is
Mishi for trainer I I don't like him
fion no he's too reaction he's too
reactionary he thinks he thinks he's
some sort of God I don't know he thinks
he's him for me he isn't uh he isn't
that good of a of a coach but I think if
we bring in uh iir daa from Balon I
think he would do great in the L manager
I think he's are ly playing good I've
seen that they're second table really
yeah in really great form in in the
Kosovo Super League uh in second place
second place I heard the managers doing
the last uh stages to become a like
licensed manager the highest level of
manager I think he'd be good as well I
think I don't know why we're keep going
for like International coaches which you
know we haven't had a good one since
shalz and then even he preo uh preo and
even he dropped in form like massively
um I think we have a lot of a lot of uh
managers here in Kore in Albania who are
really good and we've seen it with
balcon now making the conference League
two seasons in a row which is a massive
massive achievement for for a club to
them small and they're getting paid good
they're getting paid good they don't
they don't get that much money in in the
uh Kosovo Super League I think also the
problem with Koso is uh we don't have
enough we have individual talent but
they just don't show it like other than
Jova we don't really I mean we just have
to test the young players I think we are
get rid of the old ones I think we some
old ones on depend too much on him I
like morici I I don't like our play
style cuz what we do the last couple
games is just go in Cross go in Cross It
Never Lands It Never Lands much on we
need to play more I don't know we we're
good we have good individual players who
can who can dribble who can get past
oneone we don't use that their ability
though we don't see them exactly and the
Midfield is like non-existent every game
I see we're getting dominated in the
Midfield it's like defense or attack and
we don't have a Midfield at all which is
a massive problem because it's the
Midfield that controls the game sort of
speaking of national teams the euro is
coming close Albania
winning Albania wins finish the question
Albania wins yeah I think we can beat
Germany I think no Germany don't go far
I think I genuinely think Germany might
get out in group stages probably I mean
on their home turf this form this form
home turf it would be embarrassing but I
think it might happen they don't have to
play qualifying they probably lose they
did beat France though it's a friendly I
don't think France played there at first
team either no I think uh just some
players um also they they've changed
managers now again which is like the
third time in like two months or three
months Germany yeah they got nman now uh
he's good he's good he was your club's
trainer yeah I really liked him at Bon I
don't know why and they switched him out
like that I wasn't I wasn't a fan of the
decision but it happened and I'm
interested I'm I'm looking forward to
see what he's going to do with the with
the German national team in in the Euros
because they haven't been good no they
haven't been good also balandor is
coming up I think 30th yeah what do you
guys think he's going to win oh Messi
Messi it's too good man probably Messi
yeah I think it's going to be his last
balandor last last I think probably most
likely yeah unless he like comes back
for a spell at Barcelona which I don't
think he will I think he can win two
more two more come on he
two after this he's
36 he doesn't have it in him he has it
in him he doesn't want to do it I think
I think he's done everything I think he
he has football yeah he's one of the
World Cup I think inter Miami is exactly
what he needs he went there Florida he
has a nice nice house nice family he's
chill you know he doesn't have to take
football that seriously anymore he just
plays it for fun cuz uh of course the
man has a passion for it
so uh he just plays for fun you know
he's done everything uh he's the
greatest of all time the greatest of all
time and uh he deserves to rest a little
bit and I think he's deserved that much
and uh he's going to have fun in Miami
cuz uh the defending is horrible it's
horrible it makes it but I mean it's
messy he he makes it looks easy even in
the hardest made world class Defenders
look bad so so yeah it's it's
understandable but what about
Ronaldo he's finished no I think he's
doing well to be he doing well he's 38
now it's it's expected apparently
there's rumors he won't retire till
after the 2026 World Cup he wants to
play he wants to play the World Cup I
don't think he'll make the team he he's
not going to play he going be on Ben I
think I think they're going to put him
in like group stages after they they've
like qualified oh he's going to be like
a super sub no I think he's just going
to play one game and they will win it
and he's just say I have a World Cup
yeah I mean if it works yeah I mean I
don't think they're sticking the final
unless they're like 40
up still Ronaldo Ronaldo might be 40 but
he he plays and looks like a 20-year-old
he does crazy but I don't think he can
compete in the top level anymore and I
think that was really difficult for him
to to admit we could see it at Man
United last couple of months I mean it
was not his fault at man united yeah I
agree are just bad it was Collective he
wasn't he wasn't in either I think no he
was playing good the
not in the second season yeah the I
think I think if if Ronaldo went to City
I think he would still be at a top club
I don't think he would right now I think
he'd be benched by Holland yeah he'd
probably be benched by Holland but I
think he maybe go somewhere else Still
Still bened by
Alvarez to be fair I think Alvarez
should start over Holland right now he's
not in form and uh I don't think they
play the same not the same position the
same Ro yeah because Holland Holland
doesn't have de Bru yeah no I think
Alvarez plays in De Bru role now he's
play like a false n de Bru pretty much
plays as a false line plays a little bit
more far back I would say no I think
Gundam played back so rodri de Bru used
to push up a lot he used to play like a
yeah false nine he play like a cam yeah
uh but yeah I don't think I don't think
Holland is performing like uh like he
should be I don't think and I think that
coming back to the bonor thing I think
that's going to affect his chances of
winning it a lot needs to talk to him
and then you will see uh let me talk
because I think even though the balandor
is like for the last season I think of
course when people vote they're going to
be World Cup bias they're going to be
influenced by by the by the current form
as well even though it's of course off
off last season form Ian Messi also has
M stats I think yeah he has like almost
as much goals and assists as him even
though it's
and he also played with PSG yeah so yeah
but it's in it's in a weaker League
though it's in League one it's so back
to the euro thing one more time if we're
not including Albania because obviously
we're all rooting for them who do you
think is taking home the trophy
Kosovo I don't okay without Kosovo as
well realistically who probably France
have the most depth I think he yes I
don't think they win it they might not
win but but I think they'll make it
far I think far in I think actually now
that I think it's about it there aren't
many teams you know it's France I think
Portugal have a really good team Spain
have a good team Spain I forgot about
Spain I think Spain go far far I think
Spain might even win it I don't think
they will go far I don't know they have
a really good team I just don't know
what's been happening is it the coach is
it what's happening with they have they
don't shoot they just pass
took Tia too seriously so yeah uh that
concludes everything that uh we wanted
to talk about I hope you guys enjoyed
yes uh and we'll be giving out a quick
shout out to our sponsors first of all a
very big thank you to tagini for letting
us borrow the studio and letting us film
this amazing episode of the podcast yes
huge thanks to them a huge shout out to
aratex group uh they have the highest
quality of of clothing in the whole
balcans a huge shout out to sh travel
the best transportation of buses around
Europe uh and a huge shout out to CH for
their amazing store and their amazing
product quality thank
you